british suffragettes were masters of
spectacle
their mission was to win british women
the right to vote and to do that they
needed attention
their demonstrations were tightly
choreographed events full of matching
outfits and signs
but it was their radical actions that
made them notorious
they smashed windows destroyed fine art
and set fire to the houses of their
political opponents
all in the name of keeping their fight
on the front page of the paper
and in the minds of the public newsreels
from the time
show the destruction the suffragettes
left behind
but there's one act that stands out
above the rest
it took place in 1913 at one of the most
popular sporting events of the year
a horse race where new zero cameras
captured a lone figure stepping onto the
race track
and doing this
[Music]
she was holding a suffragette flag
women had been petitioning for the vote
in england since the mid-1800s
they were called suffragists and had a
non-confrontational strategy of
persuasion and
education to convince legislators to
give women the vote
but in 1903 a new branch emerged the
militant suffragists
whose motto was deeds not words
frustrated by the lack of progress they
began seeking attention by disrupting
men's political meetings with loud
heckling
and getting arrested for things like
spitting on policemen prompting one
newspaper in 1906
to call the noisy disrupters
suffragettes a name meant to diminish or
mock the new militant activists as
hysterical and childish
but one they embraced even changing the
name of their newspaper
votes for women to the suffragette
the militant suffragettes had a bad
reputation in the press and drew
criticism from the wider suffrage
movement for taking it too far
and setting progress back with their
disruptive acts the suffragettes were
depicted as
unfeminine and crazed so public
pageantry and controlling their image
was an important part of the movement
they saw themselves as crusaders for
women's freedom
so every detail was worked throughout to
make sure they made a huge
visible impact spectacle was part of the
drama of their campaign
they delivered speeches made colorful
banners marched
and got arrested in public again and
again usually wearing their official
color scheme
purple for loyalty green for hope and
white which represented the virtue of
their campaign
but also read well in sepia tone news
photos
they did make a contrast with all their
surroundings
especially when they were joined by
policemen but the militant suffragette's
publicity strategy changed in late 1910.
a riot breaks out in parliament square
and that day became known as black
friday because about 150 women
were physically and sexually assaulted
by the police
from here forward the suffragettes
organized fewer public demonstrations
where they'd be surrounded by police
shifting instead to a radical approach
of random acts of property destruction
and that's when you start to get
nationwide vandalism the telephone wires
are cut
windows is smashed sporting facilities
are attached as their actions became
more and more extreme in the early 1910s
the militant suffragettes became
notorious villains in the media
and in public opinion but their message
was clear the destruction won't stop
until a suffrage bill passes
emily wilding davidson was one of the
most extreme of the militant
suffragettes
and no stranger to violence she once
beat a man that she had mistaken for a
politician with a horse whip
she also set fire to mailboxes inspiring
some suffragettes to follow her radical
example
she was jailed nine times and while
imprisoned would go on hunger strike
and was subsequently force-fed through
her nose an extremely painful form of
torture that the government enacted on
many hunger striking suffragettes to
prevent them from dying of starvation in
prison
davison was willing to die in the name
of women's liberation
during one of her imprisonments in 1912
she threw herself from a prison balcony
in a suicide attempt
to draw public sympathy for the
suffragettes undergoing torturous
force-feeding in jail
she said afterward if i had succeeded i
am sure that forcible feeding could not
in all conscience have been resorted to
again
the following year is when davidson
pushed her dedication to deeds not words
to the most extreme
at the 1913 epsom derby the epsom derby
is england's most prestigious horse race
a beloved and historic event that's been
run since 1780.
that year over 500 000 people were in
attendance
king george v was there too his horse on
mare was running the race
and in the crowded inner track emily
davidson stood near tottenham corner
it's the final turn right before the
sprint to the finish line
a prominent spot sure to be in view of
the cameras which were positioned around
the track
covering important parts of the race in
the footage you can see davison duck
under the rail and wait for the leading
pack of horses to go by
then step out onto the track right in
front of anmer the king's horse
she was holding the purple white and
green flag of the militant suffragettes
emily davison brought the two-ton
racehorse crashing to the ground and
flipped its rider
she died four days later of her injuries
after years of escalating militant
violence was photographed after the fact
or imagined in news illustrations this
was the first
and only act of militant suffragette
violence captured on film
and it was a huge story people responded
with a mix of shock
and outrage davison was framed as a
radical who ruined something everyone
loves
the derby for the suffragettes she
became a martyr
the next issue of their magazine
featured davison as an angel on the
cover
standing on a race track they organized
a
massive public funeral where 5 000
suffragettes wearing white dresses and
black armbands
marched in solemn procession through
london carrying davison's casket from
victoria station to king's cross station
to be sent to her hometown for burial 50
000 people
watched it go by when you see
photographs of it going through the
streets
you see the sidewalk is packed with
people and people
crammed onto the balconies and they're
looking at these women like
oh it's somebody like her she threw
herself at the king's horse and she has
died
the spectacle of davidson's funeral
brought sympathy for the struggle of
women's suffrage to a global level and
as it turns out was basically the last
public procession of the militant
suffragettes
world war one broke out the following
year and the suffragettes put their
militant activities on hold to
contribute to the war effort
suffrage is extended to women over 30 in
1918 and
full suffrage passed in 1928. emily
davison's
shocking final protest at the derby
probably didn't change many people's
minds about women's suffrage
and whether or not she intended to die
remains unclear
she didn't tell anyone her plan and she
didn't leave a note
but this moment caught on camera became
one of the most publicized acts of
suffragette protest
one so extreme that no one
not even the king himself could ignore
there's so many great archival photos
and illustrations from the suffragette
movement that i didn't have time to
include in this video
like this cartoon it was published in a
british magazine in 1910 and
is called the suffragette that knew jiu
jitsu it shows terrified police officers
surrounding a lone woman
standing in front of a votes for women
sign with a few of their comrades tossed
onto the fence behind her
it might seem like a parody or a joke
but the thing is
suffragettes really did train in jiu
jitsu as a response to the continued
aggression by london police during
demonstrations
like on black friday the suffragettes
hired edith margaret garrett
a professional martial arts instructor
to teach them how to defend themselves
during riots
it's sort of unclear how often the
suffragettes used this specific skill
set
during their clashes with police but
newspapers at the time claimed these jiu
jitsu experts
could throw a 200 pound police officer
over their heads
ouch